the trains were back but not to normal
around 60 of services resuming on a day
sandwiched by strikes that have not yet
brought the nation to a halt but may
soon be testing patients i understand
why they're doing it
but i also understand i think i
understand both perspectives to be
honest yeah i'm completely for it i
think
it's right to strike when you need to i
think it should get a bit more
even though it's impacted you how it has
it scores you a lot of hassle you've
still got sympathy yeah they could do a
good job you know i mean the decent guys
the polite and the nice and kind which
you know what i mean but i think we
should be giving a little bit more yeah
hopes of a breakthrough were always slim
but disappeared altogether after less
than three hours of talks the rmt
demanding what it says is a threat of
compulsory redundancies be dropped we
came back here today seeking for that
for it to be removed so that we can
negotiate a settlement to the dispute
but we have been told now by the highest
people in network rail they don't have
the authority to say that you can
withdraw that letter there's only one
place that could say that and that's in
a department for transport so it's
pretty clear the government have
scuppered these talks
transport secretary grant shops call
that a total lie a network rails chief
negotiator concurred i'm so frustrated
because our aim this afternoon was to
move that
forward to make uh to move to the next
stage of that offer and essentially but
i can't do that on my own and i can't do
that if the rmt are walking out the room
uh you know
when at the same time they're also
threatening me with a strike tomorrow we
have to work within the funding that we
can make available
i haven't got enough money to fund a
seven percent pay rise
one train operator has settled a dispute
mersey rail agreeing a seven percent pay
rise with staff from the tssa union but
nationally network rail says the
industry faces a crisis
in 2019 before the pandemic there were
1.7 billion passenger journeys
generating 11 billion pounds of revenue
but in the last year there were just 990
million journeys almost halving income
to 5.9 billion pounds
union members say they face their own
income squeeze one conductor told us the
rising cost of living demanded action
things are getting worse as time goes on
as food prices increase and energy
prices increase and that's on my current
salary if anyone is making a move to
potentially tinker with my terms and
conditions and it's already a struggle
that's just an inevitable situation that
i'm going to have to fight to protect
myself from
[Music]
this was always a complex dispute about
more than money it's about modernization
about the future of the railway but with
relations between the two sides having
soured and the government firmly blaming
the unions there seems little chance of
substantial progress until after strikes
on thursday and again on saturday have
played out
until then the talks like many trains
will be going nowhere
paul kelso sky news in london